Florentin will mit mir mal ein Trinken gehen jetzt nach der Folge und ich sage immer nein, ich will lieber Schach spielen. Stefan ist wahrscheinlich der begabteste Spieler der Geschichte. Hatten wir schon mal besprochen. Minsk, da habe ich gespielt gegen, wer war das noch, Fabian Krane, genau, bei Rocket Beans Live.
Ich glaube, das hatten wir sogar schon mal erinnert.
Und dann, es war ganz spannend, wir konnten zwei Joker und wir konnten Grossmeister konsultieren bei jedem.
Sollen wir erst mal sagen, was wir hier machen, es ist das Podcast-Uvo-Podcast-Projekt immer noch.
Wir sind mit dabei, schön, dass du da bist.
Mir gegenüber sitzt natürlich einer der grössten Lichtgestalten der Schachkunst aller Zeiten, Stefan S. T. Hallo, Florentin W. Danke. Hast du gerade zum ersten Mal die Ansprache an den Zuschauern verändert in eine Du-Ansprache? Wir machen seit Jahren eine Ihr-Ansprache. Das stimmt. Wir sitzen unseren Zuschauern. Und deswegen, Herbert, danke, dass du dabei bist. Aber ich dachte jetzt fürs neue Jahr 24 wollen wir mal so einen persönlichen Approach wählen.
Und ich finde, Danowitsch hat uns schön die Tür aufgemacht in dieses neue Jahr. Vielen, vielen Dank für diesen harten, bassigen Klängen. Ich habe mich gefühlt so ein bisschen wie Matrix in Zion, in der schwitzigen Party, in einem Rave, wo man einfach wirklich komplett bei sich selber ist,
irgendwie schön das Blut pumpt durch den Körper, durch den Leib und man will einfach wackeln, strampeln, zappeln.
Ja?
Oder hast du das letzte Mal gewackelt, gestrampelt und gezappelt?
Du, ich tanze regelmäßig.
Ich tanze regelmäßig in der Dusche und ich glaube, es wird mich eines Tages mein Genick kosten, dass ich eines Tages, weil ich bin wirklich manchmal ein bisschen zu wild in der Dusche. Hast du so ein Duschradio? Ich habe kein Duschradio, es ist alles nur mit dem Kopf, es ist alles nur Pretty Woman. Und das Ding ist, ich habe gemerkt, ich habe so eine Badewanne als Dusche und wenn die nass ist, dann kann man da so ein bisschen hin und her rutschen. Es ist so ein bisschen mein Mrs. Doubtfire Moment, wenn die so reinrutscht in den
Türrahmen. Sorry, was ist da eigentlich stiefgelaufen? Ehrlich gesagt,
man duscht ja viel
häufig, selbst Leute, die gerne baden wie du.
Duschen vermutlich häufiger,
als dass sie baden. Natürlich.
Warum muss sich die Dusche
der Badewanne trotzdem unterordnen?
Und wir alle steigen in idiotische
Badewannen, die nie
zum Bade benutzt werden, sondern zum Duschen.
Das müsste andersrum sein.
Meinst du nicht, das ist eine Kooperation auf Augenhöhe, dass man gesagt hat, du pass auf, lass uns das zusammen machen.
Sag das nur mit dem Knie, was ich immer verrenken muss, um in die Badewanne zu steigen.
Es gibt einiges, was ich da im Knie noch sagen würde, um ganz ehrlich zu sein, aber das ist ein ganz anderes Thema, aber wir wollen nicht so totig werden.
Es ist nicht eine Kooperation, also meinst du nicht so wie damals irgendwie, keine Ahnung, ein Schlagzeugspieler und ein Gitarrenspieler haben gesagt, pass auf, wir nehmen uns die Zuschauer weg, lass uns einfach zusammenspielen. Eine Band. Genau, und so wurde die erste Band gegründet im alten Ägypten. Und so kann es ja auch sein, dass die Badewanne und die Dusche gesagt haben, ich habe das Gefühl, wir kommen gut zusammen. Gegenfrage. Die Waschmaschine, ich habe ganz schlechte Erfahrungen gemacht, ich wollte mit der zusammenarbeiten, der Toaster hat mich auf Mute, aber du, ich glaube, wir beide könnten zusammen was ganz, ganz grosses machen. Gegenfrage, inwiefern ist es eine Symbiose? Ordnen wir uns nicht dieser Drecksbadewanne mit ihren lächerlich hohen Wellen unter und erklimmen jeden Tag den Wall der Badewanne. Jähe Wallerklimmung, jeden Morgen muss man da drüber, ja das stimmt schon. Ja, haben wir nicht alle eine jähe Wallerklimmung? Moment, aber was meinst du mit Klettern? Du meinst ein beherzter Sprung. Ich stehe vor der Badewanne, gehe in die Hocke, mache einen grossen Satz, einmal in die Badewanne hinein. Team Sieg, der Startnummer 13 aus Deutschland, aus der DDR, Florentin. Komm schon, das schaffe ich. Wir haben jetzt zum ersten Mal die Leute angeschlossen mit dem Mikro. Kennen Sie vom Fussballer Football inzwischen? Wir fangen damit an. Weil wir gemerkt haben, dass sich kaum noch Leute für diesen Sport interessieren, deswegen versuchen wir hier ein bisschen persönliches Drama zu erfolgen. Wir tun alles dafür, um diese Sportart irgendwie im Leben zu erhalten. Wir würden alles tun, wir würden auch die Ergebnisse fälschen. Mit dem Code YeahSprung bekommen sie bei Clark, aber dazu gleich mehr. Jedenfalls jetzt sind der Startnummer, was habe ich gerade gesagt, 15 aus der DDR, Florentin-Wilnorek mit einem Jähnsprung in die Wanne. Aus dem Stand. Oh, aus dem Stand. Einen normalen Sprung, ohne irgendwelche Rittberger, was auch immer, Salty, einfach ein Beherzersprung. Das ist die einfachste Beherrung, aber die Lidenrichter sind begeistert. Es gibt grosse Punkte, da jemand hält die WC-Ente hoch, einer hält... Der Duschfang, oh, der Duschfang, er hängt den Duschfang, er hat sich verhangen. Aber jetzt mal ganz kurz eine wichtige Frage an dich, habe ich mich letztens überlegt, wo ist man nasser, beim Baden oder beim Duschen? Natürlich beim Baden. Ich hab, also wenn du badest und dann gehst du raus und dann trocknest du dich ab, im Gegensatz zu Dusche und du trocknest dich ab, wo wird das Handtuch nasser, wo bist du nasser am Ende?
Okay, wo wird der Raum nasser oder wo bist du nasser aber ich habe irgendwie ich habe mir so die komische vorstellung dass wenn du aus der badewanne gehst dann bleibt das wasser ja in der badewanne zurück ja verstehst du erhebst dich ja raus du gehst da raus wie wenn so eine, so eine, irgendwas aus einer Plastikpackung rausholst.
Ja.
Wohingegen bei der Dusche ist ja das Wasser auf dir drauf.
Hm.
Verstehst du grob, was ich meine?
Ja, nee, also ich würde sagen, du bist, wenn du, wenn du überlegst, wie viel Wasser am Körper ist, also Körperwasser-Koeffizienz, Berührungs-Koeffizienz, da ist natürlich viel höher im Waden.
Ja, ich muss ehrlich gesagt sagen, ich glaube dir alles.
Ja, wenn man das Wort Koeffizient, das ist immer ein Tipp für den Alltag, wenn ich das Wort Koeffizient, der ist natürlich viel höher beim Baden. Ich muss ehrlich gesagt sagen, ich glaube dir alles. Ja, wenn man das Wort Koeffizient benutzt, das ist aber ein Tipp für den Alltag, wenn ihr das Wort Koeffizient benutzt und alles sagen. Alles drin. Hey, willst du welches Bier noch trinken? Naja, mein Alkoholzeitkoeffizient ist jetzt noch nicht so vorgeschrieben wie an anderen Tagen, wie zum Beispiel Silvester. Mein Dein Bullshit zu meiner Toleranzkoeffizient ist leider aktuell so eingestellt, dass ich noch ein Bierchen brauche. Dass ich noch ein Bierchen brauche. Und man sagt, okay. Okay, er sagt, koeffizient. Okay. Ja, spannende Frage wie immer. Diese ganzen Fragen, die du aus deiner Wohnung stellst, also diese ganzen Fragen, die aufkommen bei deinem aufregenden Alltag. Wie kann ich wieder nur sagen, ja, mega krass spannende Frage. Ich habe nicht sofort eine Antwort.
Du siehst aber aus, als würdest du dich für Wasser interessieren, um ehrlich zu sein. Ja, genau, das ist sehr lustig. Ich habe mein Weihnachtsgeschenk. Ich habe mir sehr viel hier von meiner Heizungsanitärfamilie erzählt. Und ich habe jetzt bekommen zu Weihnachten, weil es kam irgendwie letztes Jahr auf, dass die Merch haben. Und mit Merch meine ich einfach Arbeitskleidung. Weil natürlich die Monteure, die rausfahren und eure Toiletten und Anschlüsse im Kreis Dortmund richten, die tragen von der Firma halt richtige, gebrandete, mit schönen Stickereien versehende Shirts. Absolut schön, das ist extrem hochwertig. Ja, und ich habe jetzt so einen Zipper und ein Shirt bekommen von der Firma meiner Familie und darunter steht Bosch Premium Partner. Also oben das Logo, also schöne Stückerei und darunter steht Bosch Premium Partner. Ich sehe aus wie ein Monteur. Ich sehe aus wie ein Monteur auf Reisen, der eure Probleme fixt, aber, turns out, kann gar nichts. Du kannst überhaupt nichts. Das heißt, wenn du jetzt irgendwie in einem Zug bist und sagst, haben wir einen Sanitär-Monteur, haben wir einen Sanitär-Monteur und du einfach nur verdeckst so deinen Bosch-Partner einfach nur so, nein, niemand. Oder kommt, Herr Bosch kommt dann und reißt mir das so ab. Wir sind nicht ein länger Bosch-Premium-Partner. Genau, wir geben dieses Etikett nicht leichtfertig, diese Stickerei. Da hast du so ein Loch hier oben, wo immer dein Nippel rausschaut, einfach zu jeder Tageszeit. Aber was ich da, ich finde das ganz toll, weil es griff genau gerade auf meine, ich habe nämlich irgendwie so eine Heimwerkerphase begonnen. Siegt ein bisschen daran, weil ich auch gerade bei dem Umzug helfe und viele Sachen abmontiere. Ich habe irgendwie Bock und ich weiß nicht, woran es liegt. Inzwischen glaube ich, dass meine Phasen, das ist eine Selbsterkenntnis, weil ich muss so viel Zeit in diesen Umzug stecken, dass ich daran so ein bisschen zugrunde gehe.
Und ich möchte, nein, aber ich habe... Klingt nicht nach einem klassischen Hobby, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen.
Und ich glaube, ich habe dann aber so eine Begeisterungsfähigkeit, dass ich mir manchmal auch Dinge einfach so schön mache,
durch, ich weiß nicht, pure, pures Reihnerdler und Begeisterung, dass die Zeit, die ich investiere, nicht mehr wie Verlorene sich anfühlt.
So ein Cobing-Mechanism, weiß ich nicht. Das können ja die Analytiker draußen entscheiden.
Aber ... Begeisterung, dass die Zeit, die ich investiere, nicht mehr wie Verlorene sich anfühlt. So ein Cobing-Mechanism, weiß ich nicht. Das können ja die Analytiker draußen entscheiden. Aber es trifft gerade auf eine Heimwerkerphase des Stephan T., der sich mit Werkzeug und Hauselektronik und so auseinandersetzt. Ich baue viel zu Hause um bei mir selber, gehe an die Haustechnik, ich mache da Kram und deswegen trifft es das ganz gut jetzt, dass ich diese Arbeitskleidung habe und war neulich im Baumarkt, hab aber vergessen, dass ich das angehabt hab noch. Und das war so unangenehm im Moment, wo ich den Baumarkt betrete und mir auffällt, dass ich halt das trage, was ich zu Hause dann jetzt so rumwerke und anziehe ganz gerne. Ich stelle den Baumarkt gestiefelt und hab dann halt dieses, diesen Monteuraufzug an, wo drunter steht Bosch Premium Partner. Du musst die Kleidung auch tragen können. Also ich will nicht zu nahe treten, aber ich finde, du hast gerade eher so einen Praktikantenlook. Ja, ja, völlig fein. Das liegt jetzt gar nicht an der Kleidung, aber es liegt natürlich auch daran, wie man es trägt, wie man sich präsentiert. Es ist der fehlende Zollstock. Es sind die orientierungslosen Augen, die suchenden Augen im Raum, wo bin ich eigentlich, die absolute Orientierungslosigkeit, der offene Mund, dieser Spuckefilm auf der Unterlippe, das ist alles so in Kombination so ein gewisses Bild, wo man einfach sagt, ja, du arbeitest in der Branche, aber du bist selbst von den Experten in der untersten Kategorie, wo ein normaler Amateur noch mithalten kann. Jetzt vergisst du aber, dass in dem Moment, wo ich den Baumarkt betreterete eine neue phase geändert habe ein enormes selbstbewusstsein habe dann den krüger-effekt selbstbewusstsein steigt bis zu dem moment an dem bin ich noch lange nicht wo man merkt na fuck das ist alles viel grösser als ich technik ist lader denn live handwerken ist lader denn live ich kann niemals rein zu lebzeiten weiss und ich bin auch gerade auf das können nur zwei drei auserwählte menschen auf der welt die wirklich talent haben wenn die können wirklich mal eine regenrinne montieren aber der normale mensch verbraucht sich da gar keine hoffnung zu machen eigentlich an diesem punkt bin ich noch nicht ich bin auch an dem punkt wo ich in meinem selbstbewusstsein in einem hybris habe ich krieg alles in lauf also mit breitem schritt laufe ich in den Supermarkt rein mit diesem Monteur-Outfit. Again, steht drauf Bosch Premium Partner. Ich laufe hin und sage dann sowas wie, Entschuldigung, wo gibt es hier die Schraubenzieher? Welche Schraubenzieher? Also wir haben die fünf Achter in Reihe drei und die drei Achter in Reihe fünf. Ja, einfach so ein normales Schlitz oder Kreuz. Ja, Schlitz, Kreuz, Stern, Dreieck, Vierheck, Fünfeck, Trapez, Parallelogramm. Wovon reden Sie denn? Was bauen Sie denn? Naja, für so eine Lampe zu Hause. Welche Lampe? Ja, so eine Lampe. Ich weiß nicht, wo die jetzt jetzt ist. Wollen Sie wissen, von wo ich die gekauft habe? Und das alles findet statt mit meinem lächerlichen Aufzug. Und die denken wirklich, ich glaube, ich mache negative Werbung für die Firma. Das stimmt, auch für Bosch, weil man fragt sich, warum hat Bosch eine Premium-Partnerschaft mit diesem Typen abgeschlossen. Aber was ist genau die Zielgruppe für Handwerker-Merch? Also ich denke sofort erstmal an Betrüger, weil was ich machen würde, ist natürlich, ich sage, ja, guten Tag, wir müssen mal ihre Waschmaschine überprüfen und dann räumst du die Wohnung aus. Und alles, was du dafür brauchst, ist so ein Handwerker-Outfit. Spannend, ja. Wer außer Betrüger ist denn noch Zielgruppe? Also wer sagt, ach Mensch, soll ich jetzt Simpsons, Garfield oder die Sanitätstechnik, Sanitärstechnik heute anziehen? Also ich habe gedacht. Ich bin Fan von allen drei. Alle drei gleich. Nee, ich habe nämlich meiner Familie gesagt, bitte, bitte, mach das doch als Merch. Das ging alles von dir aus? Nee, nee, das ist ja wirklich das originale Arbeitsoutfit der Monteure. Ich habe denen gesagt, mach doch einen Shop auf, Leute aus Dortmund, die irgendwie, keine Ahnung, Fan von lokalen Sanitäts, Sanitärbetrieben sind, oder, ich finde das ja irgendwie spannend, so Elektro, Elektromünch oder sowas, fährt durch Köln, und wenn die dann, ich finde es irgendwie cool, von denen Merch zu haben, ich glaube, das passt gerade in die Zeit, alle tragen Thriftjob-Sachen, Es passt irgendwie in die Zeit, um sehr viel Geld auszugeben für einen
lokalen Handwerkerbetrieb.
Ich würde ehrlich gesagt Geld dafür bezahlen.
Für, weiß ich nicht, Malerei Spauke.
Sind wir durch Kam gefahren.
Malerbetrieb Spauke.
Und dann was hinten drauf und dann haben die auch so trashige
nichts gegen dieses Firmenlogo
meiner Familie.
Aber es ist halt so ein bisschen oldschool. Ich finde das sogar noch cool. Aber das ist irgendwie so die Frage. Hat es nicht Kult wert? Ich sehe das aber skeptisch ein bisschen, weil ich finde, da wird so ein bisschen an den Grundfundamenten der Gesellschaft gerüttelt. Weil natürlich so eine Uniformität natürlich auch einen gewissen Sinn hat, dass man Leute erkennt, dass man weiss, okay, das ist eine Seriosität. Wenn das sich jetzt jeder kaufen kann, wenn die Polizei-Merch irgendwie dann diese Polizeiuniformen verkauft und du sagst, das ist kultig als Polizist oder als Feuerwehrmann rumzulaufen.
Ich meine, dann ist einfach erstens das ganze Jahr Karneval, wo zieht man dann die präzise Trennlinie?
Wie viel ist das Karneval, was ich gerade mache?
Es hat für mich Karneval, na gut, er ist einer der Bauarbeiter, der andere ist der Heizungsmann, er ist halt ein sehr langweiliger Karneval irgendwie. Also es ist halt so ein Alltagskarneval irgendwie, so ein bisschen die, wie heißen die Five People? Die Village People. Die Village People. Da ist keine Heizung sanitär, das stimmt. Die Village People sind ja, na gut, okay. Ist da ein Ritter dabei? Ich glaube nicht. Kauber dabei? Ich weiß gar nicht genau. Kauber, Indianer. Wir sind auch nicht nur Alltagssachen, ja, stimmt schon. Aber so muss ich schon sagen, ich will mich auf Leute vertrauen können, ich lebe von Oberflächlichkeit, ich will Leute anschauen können und sofort wissen, in welche Schublade kommst du, wie muss ich mit dir umgehen, was ist los, bist du Arzt, bist du Alästhesist? Haben wir nicht diese Uniformitätszeit überholt? Man kann Leuten die mir vom Kopf gucken und wissen, dass Ärzte nicht so aussehen wie Ärzte früher aussehen.
Es ist so, ja, weiß ich nicht, die sind jünger, früher. Früher haben Ärzte Anzüge getragen, ich habe letztens Fotos angeschaut von einem alten Krankenhaus und da hatten die alle einfach Anzüge an, so das war ganz merkwürdig, weil es ein ganz anderes Gefühl plötzlich ist. Du denkst, du bist in so einer Werbefirma, so ein Don Draper Look, das ist ganz interessant und irgendwann haben wir gesagt einfach so ein komplett anderes Gefühl. Und da habe ich eben Angst, dass das so ein bisschen auf wird. Aber du meinst auch so, wie man heute in der Businesswelt keine Anzüge mehr unbedingt trägt, sondern der legerere Chef, irgendwie der lockere. Bin ich aber auch kein Fan davon. Ich finde, klare Unterscheidbarkeit. Aber ich jetzt zum Beispiel als jemand mit dem Beruf des Podcasters. Okay. Wir haben keine Arbeitsoutfits. Noch nicht. Da würde ich sagen, lass uns lieber daran arbeiten, dass wirklich jede Berufsgruppe einen eigenen Look hat. Weil ich meine, du kannst, wenn du sagst, keine Werbe-Fuzzi, kannst du dich verkleiden oder so Medientrottel, gibt es einfach auch im Kostümshop Kostüme, die du kaufen kannst, wo du so aussiehst. Podcaster ist doch nicht so ganz, außer das breitbeinige Sitzen und dieses Mikrofon, was man dann so irgendwie über hinten tragen müsste. Was mir gefällt, ist die grossen klobigen Kopfhörer. Die gefallen mir sehr. Wir haben diese riesen Mickey Mouse-esken Kopfhörer. Ihr könnt übrigens alles sehen, wenn ihr uns bei Patreon folgt. Nur ganz kurz. Unsere riesen klobigen Kopfhörer, wo wir immer überall hängen bleiben.
Aber es ist auch tatsächlich Ohrenwärmer. Ich bin ja viel mit dem Fahrrad unterwegs, obwohl Schneegestöber an der Tagesordnung ist. Und da habe ich ja auch immer meine Noise-Canceling-Kopfhörer dabei, die gleichzeitig natürlich auch als Isolationstechnik, aber auch als Ohrenwärmer funktionieren. Also ich bin da ganz zufrieden. Er trägt natürlich keinen Helm dann, aber ich habe mir trotzdem in meinem Kopf immer die Vorstellung, weil immer wenn ich mich aufs Fahrrad schwinge, denke ich mir, du hast keinen Helm auf, Vorsicht, du könntest heute sterben. Und dann sage ich, okay, aber was ist, wenn ich genau aufs linke Ohr falle? Haben diese Kopfhörer, also du musst ja, wenn du einen Helm produzierst, musst du so Crash-Tests machen. Was ist mit Kopfhörern? Gibt es da irgendjemand, der sagt, Moment mal, lass uns mal testen, ob man nicht vielleicht mehr stirbt, wenn man auch drauf fällt oder ist es allen egal? Eine mega gute Idee, wir bringen Kopfhörer raus, die genau wie dieser Airbag-Helm. Das hat dieser Schal, den du trinkst.
Okay. Du meinst die dann im Moment der Gefahr so.
Genau, es gibt nämlich, was ich fantastisch finde und auch ein bisschen lustig. Und ein Kumpel von mir hat das auch. Das ist so ein Schal, das ist diese schwedische Firma. Ja, alle Sprachen, alle Sprlegt, alle fühlen sich gleich angegriffen, die ganze Welt.
Alle fühlen sich angegriffen, macht damit, was ihr wollt. Jedenfalls ein grosser Ring um den Hals und der bei einer Erschütterung wird ausgelöst und macht einen Airbag-Helm um dich. Was ich unglaublich toll finde und lustig. Super witzig finde, ist, wenn das schlicht und einfach nicht stimmen würde, sondern die einfach nur diese Kragen verkaufen, die gar nichts machen, aber alle Leute, die stürzen, sind tot und können sich nicht beschweren, also ist das eigentlich ein perfektes Marketingkonzept, die machen einfach nix. Die lösen zu schnell aus, auch albern. Schau mal vor, du hast irgendwie Date, erst date, man verabschiedet sich und so.
Genau.
Ciao, ich habe hier sehr viel Spaß gemacht.
Ja, danke.
Umarmung, man umarmt sich noch und dann so, ich mache schon mal meinen Helm auf.
Wir haben ja darüber gesprochen, das ist auf jeden fall richtig cool ja es war ein richtig gutes date jetzt wo ich noch mal so die highlights revue passieren dass als du über deinen helm der eigentlich kein helm ist gesprochen wir haben uns lustig gemacht über die banalen dinge des lebens ich finde es wirklich okay ja es war ein wirklich es war ein interessanter blick aufs alltagsgeschehen ja nur weil du die ganze Zeit die Diebdeile in deine, komm, da fangen wir jetzt nicht mit an. Nee. Jetzt ist ja auch, ciao, mach's gut. Tschüss, ne, ciao. Sie fliegt weg, eher weil die Erschütterung eine Erschütterung des Herzens. Ja, absolut, so ein Kussversuch kann ja auch als Bedrohung wahrgenommen werden, sodass der Helm sagt, Alarm, Alarm, Alarm, zack, schiesst es los. Ich hätte aber auch Angst, dass einfach mein Kopf abgerissen hat. Aber ich hätte gerne einen Helm für andere Situationen natürlich. Ja. Ein selbstauslösender Helm oder Schutz für, zum Beispiel ich bin sehr anfällig, weil so Fremdscham scheiß, dass ich immer weggucke oder die, man kann die Ordner nicht zumachen, aber so, ich schnappe dann die, ich schnappe dann die Augen zu und denke, ich kann das nicht sehen. Wenn ich einen Film gucke, wo eine Fremdscham-Szene im Gange ist, zu kommen, wird Leertaste gedrückt. Leertaste? Oder es wird langsam zugeklappt. Okay. Aber ich kann damit nicht rumgehen. Ich kann nicht weggucken, das reicht nicht. Okay. Und deswegen hätte ich gerne so einen, wie den Helm, nur wo die Augen zugehen und die Ohren so zugemacht werden.
Finde ich eine gute Idee. Aber woran
misst ihr das? Also das ist dein
Gehirnströmung und dann wenn dein
Puls steigt, dann wirst du einfach
komplett abgeschottet. Genau, abgeschottet.
Und bis es dann, bis die Situation vorüber ist.
Okay. Man geht so langsam wieder
auf. Ja.
Und dann wieder zu, falls irgendwas, auch wenn
was Dummes passiert. Also genau, ein Freund von mir war bei der letzten Wetten, das Aufzeichnung. Und dann wieder zu, falls irgendwas, auch wenn was Dummes passiert. Ein Freund von mir war bei der letzten Wetten-das-Aufzeichnung und er erzählt, das war der unangenehmste Moment und bei Wetten-das kannst du ja da nicht im Publikum sitzen. Nja, stopp, es ist unangenehm, es ist cringe, sondern er muss es ertragen. Klar, du bist ja da auch gefesselt, du bist ja da fixiert auf den Stühlen. Und die Kamera ist auf dich gerichtet, du kannst nicht mal sagen. Du kannst mit Augenschlag Morse-Code versuchen, aber mehr ist nicht. Help, help. Weil die Szene war, Chair war da und Chair hat gesungen vorher, setzt sich dann auf die Couch, auf dem Chair. Chair sitzt auf dem Couch, okay.
Chair sitzt auf dem Sofa.
Okay.
Und daneben war Jan-Josef Liefers, der dann die Gitarre hervorgeholt hat und hat gesagt,
aber wir haben uns übrigens, ich und meine Frau haben uns klingelern zum Song von The I Got You, Babe.
Und hat dann angefangen, ohne Skills und Verstand und Charisma, diesen Song zu spielen.
Das ist genau das Gegenteil von Chair eigentlich. Vor der Frau, von der der Song ist, die daneben sitzt und sagt, ja. Und es war wohl sehr unangenehm und ich verstehe das und ich konnte mir das nicht mal in den Highlight Reads, die bei TikTok oder so hochgeladen wurden, selbst da konnte ich es mir nicht angucken, sondern er musste es wegmachen und er saß im Publikum, da hätte ich gerne so eine Brille, die macht ja die ist sofort fixiert. Und dann stell dir mal vor, du siehst das Publikum, er holt die Gitarre raus und
einzeln wie so Popcorn, aber im Publikum wie bei Helmen.
Aber dann dauert es auch immer eine Weile und dann gehen die wieder so alle weg. Popcorn, das ist richtig gut. Wie im Publikum. Du singen alle so eine weisse Helm. Und Elten auf der Couch auch, einfach so. Einmal einer auf der Couch. Ist eine gute Idee, man muss natürlich nur irgendwie das Cringe-Zentrum dann finden, da musst du die Nadel genau richtig in den Schädel rammen. Nadel in Schädel, mehr, das ist mein Vorsatz für 2024. Okay. Mehr Nadel in Schädel. Schädel in Rammen. Ja, okay, gut. Ja, ich finde es gut, ich mag diese Helme sehr, ich finde die fantastisch. Und den könntest du dir holen. Und ich weiß aber nicht, ob der mit Kopfhörern funktioniert, ob die Kopfhörer dann Reisst du denn, schieß die Kopfhörerhörer nach oben weg. Ins All. Ja. Aber das fände ich noch okay. Problematisch wäre, wenn du Verletzungen davonträgst, weil die sich verheddern oder so. Oder der löst nicht aus, weil du Kopfhörer auf hast. Mein Problem ist, es ist ja ein ständiges Stürzen. Also wenn du im Schnee unterwegs bist auf eiskalter Fläche, dann bist du ja ständig am Stürzen. Da kann nicht ständig das irgendwie aufgehen und so. Das ist natürlich dann schon schwierig. Warst du viel im Schnee unterwegs jetzt? Ich bin viel im Schnee unterwegs, ja. In Hamburg bin ich immer auf dem Rad, Radesel unterwegs. Und da ist ja die geniale Idee, dass du an den Seitenstreifen der Strasse hast du so einen Fahrradweg und wenn dann Schnee geräumt wird, dann schieben die den ganzen Schnee von der Strasse auf den Fahrradweg. Ah, super. Weil man einfach sagt, wir haben ganz klar Parteiergriffen für die Autofahrer, Wir sind ganz klar Team Autofahrer und es gibt keine Lobby für den Fahrradfahrer Schneeschieber. Also ich habe auch schon überlegt, ob man nicht so einen Schneeschieber ans Fahrrad machen könnte, um den Schnee wieder auf die Strasse zurückzuschieben. Es gibt doch diese Schaufel. Und dann sagen die so, hey, hey. Das ist das selber, so selber. Ja genau, Spiegel, Schneespiegel und dann schieben die das einfach immer hin und her. Super. Deswegen, ich frage mich auch, warum nicht einfach da mit Flammenwerfern gearbeitet wird in der Schneebeseitigungstechnik. Die Laubbläser des Schnees. Ja, einfach, ich stelle mir wirklich so ein Mad Max-eskes Gerät vor, wo jemand oberkörperfrei mit einer E-Gitarre irgendwie steht und um ihn herum einfach tausend Flammenwerfer einfach das kompletten Schnee einfach komplett wegdampft, einfach in der kompletten Strasse, sodass da eine Schneise der Verwüstung ist, alles wird weggebrannt und man kann einfach ohne weiteres da durchfahren. Hey, Sie haben meinen Hund weggeflammt und dann so ins für die Fresse dann selber. Für die Beschwerden geh nach links. So was, warum denn nicht, warum nicht die Hamburger Verkehrsbetriebe einfach mal so einen Teil auch in ihre Flotte aufnehmen. Aber Frage. Ja, Richter-Hustechnik-Sanitär. Genau, Bosch Premium Partner. Der erste Reihe, bitte. Genau, und zwar hatte ich jetzt gerade die Idee, wir könnten doch einfach eine Schneeschaufel nehmen, den Griff abmachen und das Vorlandsfahrrad montieren. Nicht nur sind fahren wir selber sicherer, weil wir nicht auf Schnee fahren, sondern den Schnee vorher wegschöppen, sondern wir machen auch für die nachfolgenden Fahrradfahrer den Fahrradweg frei.
Ich krempel für Sie mal meine Hose hoch, damit Sie mal meine Beine sehen können.
Schauen Sie sich mal diese Beine an. Fällt Ihnen was auf?
Wunderschöne Waden.
Ja, aber fällt Ihnen auch noch was auf?
Blutig.
Klein und schwach.
Klein und schwach, ach so.
Ja.
Glauben Sie, dass ich mit diesen Beinen hier, können alle sehen?
Ja, ja.
Können alle die Beine sehen?
Letzte Reihe. Kannst du es ein bisschen höher heben? Ich versuche es ein, ich versuche es ein bisschen höher sehen, ah, danke schön, ja, schlecht wach. Und glauben Sie, dass ich wirklich mit den Beinen diese Tonnage an Schnee vor mir herschieben kann, nein. Nächste Frage, Friseur Dietrichs. Ja, ich hatte mir vorgestellt, dass, weil Haare im Ozean führen dazu, dass man Öl aufsaugen kann oder Verschmutzung oder sowas. Ich dachte, wir versuchen mal das ganze, die ganzen Haarreste, die wir im Lager haben, ist voll, ist komplett voll, wenn wir diese ganzen Haarreste mal auf den Schnee k Schnee kippen. Okay, damit die Haare den Schnee aufsagen?
Also wir wissen es noch nicht, das hat noch niemand gemacht, aber vermutlich hat es auch
einen guten Effekt.
Weil wie gesagt, es ist alles voll.
Ja, können Sie sich darum kümmern?
Es quillt alles aus dem Lager heraus.
Wir müssen jetzt halt natürlich eine neue Art von Gefährt bauen, was Haare auf den
Boden schmeißt.
Mhm, wie zum, ja. Okay, kriegen wir hin. Kriegen wir hin. Gut, alles klar. Innung, die Innung hat getagt. Innung. Innung? Naja, Friseur-Innung. Ich weiß nicht genau, was es ist, glaube ich, so eine Art Zusammenschluss aus, wie es Friseur-Meister betrieben ist. So ist es wie eine Zunft. Ja, eine Zunft. Zunft, Gilde, Indung, Worte, deren Bedeutung wurden bekannt. Wörter, deren Bedeutung uns entfallen. Egal sind, die wir schon mal gelernt, aber dann innerhalb von kürzester Zeit wieder vergessen haben. Genauso wie Hanse, wo ich auch irgendwie glaube ich einmal im Monat nachlese und sage, jetzt muss ich aber mir mal Gedanken machen, was heißt das eigentlich, Geschichte, man denkt ja bei Geschichte immer nur so an Religion und Krieg, aber nein, auch die Wirtschaftsgeschichte ist ja wichtig, ja, also wir haben Leute gehandelt, wir haben Leute sich zusammengetan, unglaublich, und dann liest du das durch, meine Augen könnten nicht grösser sein, und wirklich, also ich glaube, das Gehirn, dadurch, dass wir so viel scrollen, fungiert das Gehirn auch genau wie ein scrollender Bildschirm. Du hast immer genau in deinem Arbeitsspeicher, was auf dem Bildschirm ist. Und sobald du runterscrollst, ist alles, was oben ist, sofort wieder vergessen. Was nicht mehr im Bild ist, ist vergessen. Und so kannst du den kompletten Artikel lesen, unten ankommen und hast alles wieder vergessen, weil du dich einmal durchgescrollt hast. Aber ich habe ganz viele Tabs auch auf. Es war alles einmal in deinem Gehirn, aber es wurde alles auch wieder rausgebracht.
Frage, erzähl mir ein bisschen was, also nicht Frage, Aufforderung, erzähl mir ein bisschen was über die Hanse.
Naja, die Hanse ist natürlich deswegen so interessant, weil sie natürlich eine Gegenbewegung zu den Gilden und Zünften dargestellt hat, die natürlich lokal begrenzt waren, hat die Hanse gesagt, nee, wir machen das überall.
Wir machen schön die Hanse, machen wir schön überall,
damit das alles, wenn die hier ankommen,
damit wir da schön ein bisschen
die Eltscheffel können.
Nee, wir sind auch im Rheinland.
Wir sind auch im Rheinland, ja, dort kannst du machen.
Wo geht die Hanse durch? Ist das eine Hansestrasse?
Der Helwig? Ja, es ist eine Hansestadt,
die natürlich vor allem am Hafen liegt.
Ist ja klar, Hansen und Hafen hat natürlich immer was.
Meine Heimatstadt.
So, und es darf natürlich ein Schiff nicht einfach überall anlegen, weil du hast natürlich Zölle, Zünfte, sowas. Innungen. Deswegen Innungen, deswegen sagt man, nee, die Schiffe müssen alle, dürfen alle nur in der Hansen anlegen, damit wir das alles kontrollieren können, damit die Zölle zahlen, damit die irgendwie Standplätze bezahlen, damit die nicht einfach schwarz irgendwo anlegen. Super. Und da hat die Hanse natürlich einiges davon, ist ja klar.
Das ist ja klar. Da kommt Geld rein, da kommt Zaster, da kommt Sirup auf dem Pfannkuchen, sag ich mal. Wenn du verstehst, was ich meine. Er kennt nicht, nein. Wenn du verstehst, was ich meine. Die haben ordentlich Wachs am Docht. Wenn du verstehst, was ich meine. Die haben einen großen Schwanz. Nein, nein, nein.
Ich meine, da sind zwei Schokobons in einer Packung drin, wenn du verstehst, was ich meine.
Ah, okay.
Verstehst du, was ich meine?
Der hat ordentlich Taster dahinter, kneten Moneten, der hat ordentlich Pfeffer am Stock.
Ich weiß nicht, was ich meine.
Der hat ordentlich die Adialetten an den Füssen.
Stefan, verstehst du, was ich meine?
Einen dicken Hintern? Nein, verstehst du, was ich meine? Der hat ein schönes Rapsol in der Fritteuse, du, aber richtig. Was zu bieten im Bett. Nein, es hat überhaupt nichts mit Erotik und Sex zu tun. Ah, okay, ach so, ach so, sorry. Es ging einfach nur um Geld. Bei der Hanse ging es einfach nur um Geld. Sie sagen das so zotig. Hattest du das schon mal, dass du einen Schokobon aufgemacht hast und da waren zwei drin? Nein. Ich auch nicht. Das ist mein größter Traum. Das ist lange drüber nachgedacht. Das ist mein größter Traum. Das ist wirklich mein größter Traum, dass ich einmal so eine, vor allem du siehst es ja von außen nicht, du machst die Schokobon auf und dann denkst du, oh nein, zwei. Ist das dein, sag mir nicht, dass das dein Jahresvorsatz ist. Wenn dervorsatz ist es, naja, das ist ja eine rein statistische Frage. Wenn du ganz viel Schokobons isst, irgendwann muss ja ein Schokobon sein, wo zwei drin sind. Nee, nee, überhaupt nicht, überhaupt nicht. Oder du sagst, zwei, oder du gehst zum Hähnchenstand, sagst, ich hätte gerne ein halbes Hähnchen, und dann machst du es auf und es ist ein ganzes Hähnchen. Das ist ein riesen Schokobon. Ich meine, das sind halt die Dinge. Ja. Nein, nein, nein, nein, hör auf nicken, nicken nicht, nicken nicht, ist Unsinn. Da hat mir aus Versehen ein hähnchengrosses Schokobong. Weiß man nicht, soll ich mich beschweren oder nicht, oder ist es gut? Und in zehn Jahren sitzt du hier und sagst, und das will ich haben mit zwei riesen Schokobongs. Ja, man kriegt ja nicht genug, du kriegst deinen Hals nicht voll. Du kriegst den Hals nicht voll. Der Hals ist ein bodenlose Schokobon.
Der Hals ist der Keller des Mundes.
Denk da mal drüber nach.
Nee, der Lastenfahrstuhl des Mundes.
Der Aufzug des Mundes.
Keller ist sozusagen Bauch.
Der Gaumen ist das Dach des Mundes.
Aber wir sind dann schon, ehrlich gesagt, sehr weit oben.
Also wenn das das Dach ist, sind wir halt, das ist ja vierter Stock. Ja, das stimmt. Wenn der Keller, der Bauch ist. Und der Hals, der Aufzug. Der Aufzug. Wo ist das Treppenhaus? Die Luftröhre? Speiseröhre. Aber auf der anderen Seite, eines geht ja hoch und runter, eines geht nur runter. Also Speiserühe geht ja nur runter, Luftühe geht ja hoch und runter.
Oh, da hast du aber noch nie Silvester krass durchgezogen. Ich meine, Silvester war tatsächlich eher erreichenslos. Ja, hast du nicht viel gefeiert, nicht viel gefeiert, nicht 2024 willkommen geheißen. Und das ist so geil, weil ich hab's jetzt schon wieder fast vergessen, aber ich muss mich aktiv daran erinnern, um das nicht zu vergessen, und zwar ich hatte extreme Rückenschmerzen, mal wieder. Ja, ich habe tatsächlich im Podcast Super Achiv nachgeschaut. Ja, ja.
Und stellt sich heraus, wir hatten tatsächlich schon eine Folge namens Rücken, deswegen will ich da gar nicht zu sehr darauf eingehen.
Wir haben schon Rücken zwei, ich habe Alphabet zwei aber auch schon.
Weil ich hatte wieder starke Rückenschmerzen und habe Silvester in der Badewanne verbracht.
Und es ist so interessant, weil jetzt habe ich die nicht mehr die Rückenschmerzen und bin wieder völlig quietschfidel
und vergesse einfach, dass es mir richtig, richtig schlecht ging ein paar Tage, weil ich richtig harte Rückenschmerzen hatte. Und ich habe versucht, was ich konnte. Ich habe mir ein Kirschkernkissen gekauft. Ja, kkk. Und dann heißt es bei dem gekauften Kirschkernkissen, dass ich das im Backofen aufheizen soll. Sind Kirschkerne wirklich die besten Kerne oder sagt man das gern Kirschkernkissen und deswegen Kirschkerne, aber eigentlich sind die Kerne von Wassermelonen viel besser, aber Wassermelonenkernkissen sagt doch keiner gern. Ja, das ist Marketing so, ja, möchten Sie einmal die Pflaumenkernkisten, wollen Sie eine Kiste Pflaumenkernkissen oder wollen Sie eine Kiste Kirschkernkissen. Kissen oder wollen Sie eine Kiste Kirschkernkissen? Dann sagt man ja nicht in die Kiste Kirschkernkissen, klaro. So und dann verkauft sich das natürlich besser. Ich weiss nicht, was die Magie der Kirsche ist, warum die Kirsche sagt, ähm, sorry, ich bin köstlich, von mir gibt's zwei und by the way. Wir können Wärme speichern. Kirsche. Wir sind die Kirschkindkissen, wir können Wärme speichern. Aber ich finde, also Kirsche glaube ich wäre das Obst, was ich am wenigsten gern wäre. Ah nein, liebe ich, liebe ich. Aber pass auf, sei vorsichtig. Du denkst immer nicht nach, wenn du dir Sachen wünschst. Du kriegst den Genie und sagst, ich wäre gerne Kirsche. So, weil bei Kirsche, die hängen ja immer zu zweit ab. Du hängst zu zweit und vor allem, die haben so Körperkontakt die ganze Zeit. Stell dir vor, es sind so zwei Schaukeln, die am selben Punkt aufgehängt wurden und unten sitzen zwei Leute, die immer so ein bisschen sich aneinander drücken, weil die am gleichen Punkt aufgehängt sind. Frage. Super unangenehm. Aber nur für eine Saison. Ja, aber eine Saison kann verdammt lang sein. Ich sag nur, nur für eine Saison. Ihr wisst selber zu Hause, wie lang so eine Saison ist, müssen wir jetzt nicht ins Detail gehen. Aber man hängt für so eine Saison. Da müssen wir jetzt nicht eine Zahl umzuwärten. Überhaupt nicht. Wir sind fachchinesisch. Wir sagen einfach, also wir sagen mal jetzt, um es zu vereinfachen, man hängt ja nur eine Saison dran. Das stimmt. Und was ich auch noch sagen muss, ich glaube, du bist ein Obst, Hängeobst und du hängst da rum, die ganze Zeit. Ja? Sei doch froh. Sei doch verdammt nochmal froh, wenn da da jemand dabei ist. Seven vs Wild Teams. Alle sind fröhlich. Ist das wirklich ein gutes Beispiel? Ist das die beste Staffel von denen? Ich weiss es nicht. Nein, aber die haben auf jeden Fall kein Problem mit Isolation. Es kommt natürlich stark darauf an, mit wem du zusammen, mit dem du gematcht wirst, klar. Wenn du mit einem coolen, interessanten Gefährten, irgend so einem Astronauten oder so. Nein, ist auch eine fucking Kirsche. Auch eine fucking Kirsche. Aber im Apfelbaum musst du halt mega lange rufen, zum nächsten Apfel. Du hängst da alleine rum. Aber wenn wir da beide an so einem Kirschbaum hängen. Hallo! Stell dir mal vor, wie wir heute hängen da im Kirschbaum. So, wir beide. Ja. Stefan. Du, Stefan. Hey, Stefan. Ich schlafe. Ich stelle mich schlafend. Stefan, kann ich mal recht sein? Das haben wir schon gestern versucht. Darf ich einmal recht sein, bitte? Ja, komm. Ich habe jetzt schon so eine Druckstelle hier. Okay, pass auf, pass auf. Wir brauchen ein paar Regeln, wenn wir jetzt hier eine Saison lang hängen. Ja, von März bis, ja, also, ist ja egal. Aber dann meine ich nur, wenn wir jetzt hier eine Saison lang zusammenhängen, warum müssen wir ein paar Regeln haben? Ein paar Regeln. Okay, keine Witze mehr, das ist meine Regel, du machst keine Witze mehr. Zweitens, du darfst mich nur dreimal am Tag ansprechen. Okay, was heißt Tag? Wie viele Saison, wie viele Tage hat die Saison? Also dreimal am Tag, das wäre wie oft in der Saison. Also ungefähr grob überschlagen. Okay, vergiss die Regel, vergiss die Regel. Wir sagen einfach, die ganze Saison darfst du mich nur 50 Mal ansprechen. 50 Mal pro Saison, okay, das wäre dann auf den Tag gerechnet. Okay, vergiss diese Tage, okay? Ich möchte einfach nur meine Ruhe haben, weil wir sind ja zusammen in einem Boot. Ich nerve dich doch auch wahrscheinlich. Es ist halt so, wir hängen jetzt zusammen. Überhaupt nicht. Du kannst mich immer ansprechen, du kannst mit mir immer reden, wenn du willst. Okay. Ich glaube, du unterschätzt, wie lang diese Saison sein kann. Das stimmt, manchmal habe ich Schwierigkeiten, mir die Länge der Saison wirklich vor Augen zu führen. Aber warum musst du immer recht sein? Weil wir so gewachsen sind. Ja, das sagst du. Ja, es sind Facts. Komm, okay, versuch's, wir versuchen's noch einmal. Okay, einmal noch. Drei? Wir reiben unsere Nussre Bäuche aneinander. Wir reiben unsere grossen, runden, roten Bäuche aneinander. Unsere knallroten, prallen Bäuche. Das fühlt sich gut an. Das fühlt sich tatsächlich gut an. Meinst du, wir sind schon reif? Ja. Ich bin reif. Ich bin auch reif. Da sind sie gefallen. Auf den Bögen. Nacheinander. Da sind sie gepoppt. Kirschen. Kann man noch andere Körner poppen, oder ist Mais das einzig popbare? Sehr, sehr gute Frage. Die grosse Verwirrung, die sich bei mir immer einstellt, ist bei Puffreis, wo ich mir denke, ich habe in meinem Leben schon eine Menge Reis gemacht. Noch nie, aber auch wirklich noch nie, stand der Reistopf auf dem Herd und plötzlich so Das war nie passiert. Nee, das ist, glaube ich, tatsächlich noch nie passiert. Okay, du wartest auf die zwei Schokobons in einem und das Super Mario Theme vom ... Hähnchengrosse Schokobon. Und das Super Mario Theme vom Popcorn. Es muss doch mal passiert sein, oder? Es muss doch mal passiert sein. Ich muss immer noch lachen darüber, dass du gerade dich versprochen hast und es korrigiert hast mit dem Versprecher. Und was ich, weil es so lustig ist, wenn Leute es versprechen, manchmal machen sie zu viel danach. Ja. So, sag einfach, oder man verhaspelt sich in einem Ja, genau. Da müssen wir noch mal den Koeffizienten, den Koeffizienten, den Koeffizienten, den Koeffizienten, meine ich. Ich habe das immer gehasst. Das war auch so ein Ding, wo mein Kopf wäre verdeckt gewesen, bis von diesem hellen Cringe-Helm, wenn in der Schule damals immer Referaten von Klassenkameraden, die sie versprochen haben, versprochen haben, und dann immer machen sie so weirden Scheiss, um es zu überspielen. Aber sie sind noch nicht in dem Modus, wo sie selbstbewusst das überspielen können, weil sie sind noch unangenehm angetatscht, angefasst.
Ja, es ist ja eigentlich ein eher selbstbewusstes Anerkennen, dass man gerade einen Fehler gemacht hat. Okay, wir haben es alle gesehen, jetzt ich weissugebaden! So, ähm, also, Koeffizient wollte ich nochmal sagen, und einfach geht's ganz locker weiter. Ich mag mal, das ist auch auf die Zunge. Boah, das ist so, ich weiß nicht, warum machen das Leute? Die Zunge ist schuld. Man will sagen, die Zunge ist schuld. Wenn ihr euch, ja, ich weiß, aber niemand, alle wissen, dein Gehirn ist schuld. Vielleicht ist es eine Mischung aus verschiedenen Komponenten, die wie schief gelaufen.
Komm, komm, blablabla, oh, ich funktioniere euch nicht, oh, erst mal wach werden, dumm, dumm, Enttäuschung für die ganze Familie, blablabla, sorry, sorry, Kaffee, mehr Kaffee, damit ich funktioniere, amon.
So, und man denkt, sie macht keine riesen Nummer draus, das ist keine One-Walking-One-Man-Show, ihr füllt alle euer kleines Theater auf, fucking lass das, einfach wieder weitermachen. Und wenn ihr euch wieder versprecht, auch egal, wir alle wollen das nicht. Und wenn ihr euch im nächsten Satz wieder versprecht, weitermachen, nicht dann, was macht es, warum sollte man sich das antun, in der Öffentlichkeit diesen Scheiss zu machen. Ja, ja, stimmt schon, aber es kann natürlich auch ein selbstbewusster Umgang damit sein und zu sagen, okay, reset, es geht weiter. Egal in was, wenn dein selbstbewusster Umgang ist, zu machen, macht's nicht einfach, das wäre mein Take. Ja, vor allem halt nicht jetzt irgendwie bei einer ernsten Ansprache oder so, wenn ihr die Beerdigung haltet oder irgendwie, keine Ahnung, bei einer Gedenkfeier sprecht oder so. Und die 50.000 gestorbenen, äh, gestorbenen, die 50.000 gestorbenen. Ich weiß nicht, was ist los. Ich weiß nicht, was los ist. Okay.
Ich fang nochmal an.
Autounfälle sind in Deutschland mittlerweile.
Ja, es ist schwierig.
Das machen so viele Menschen.
Die machen da so eine grosse Nummer drauf.
Ich finde es lustig.
Das geht nicht.
Nee, das geht nicht. Vielleicht ist das euerer Jahresversatz? Ja, weniger sowas machen, weil ich kann das was sein. Da würde immer mein Cringe-Helm angehen. Lass uns das mal bauen. Jedes Mal dein Cringe-Helm. Ja, lass uns das mal. Meine, meine, meine, meine, meine, meine, meine, meine Idee für 2024 wäre nämlich, einfach mal was umzusetzen. Wir haben viele Ideen, wir können mal was umsetzen. Ja, ich habe auch schon freudig darauf gewartet, dass Leute im Reddit posten, wie sie Pizzaturm spielen. Kein einziger Mensch. Dafür muss ich sagen, hat das Reddit natürlich wieder die Lebert. Ich habe nämlich vor einigen Wochen hier eine... Hat es? Ja, jetzt muss ich die erst mal finden. Und zwar habe ich vor einigen Wochen hier Nele und nach der der Vampire vorgelesen, nämlich eine Kindergeschichte, die ich im Alter von sieben Jahren geschrieben habe. Und wir haben uns hier kaputt gelacht und gedacht, holy shit, als Siebenjähriger macht man dusselige Dinge.
Und vor allem war es irgendwie auch eine fucking lustige Story, die aber nicht zu Ende geführt wurde. Ja, finde ich jetzt nicht. Es wurden viele Bilder gemacht von KI, sehr, sehr süss, auf jeden Fall so im Pixar-Style. Hab's gefunden. Nämlich hat das Reddit richtig clever die ganze Geschichte bei ChatGPT hochgeladen und OpenAI ein Ende schreiben lassen, ein befriedenes Ende. Alles abgetippt, das ist krass. Ich hoffe, es hat meinen Duktus übernommen als Siebenjähriger und diese kleinen Stilmittel, dass man plötzlich ein falsches Präteritum benutzt oder sowas. Wäre natürlich schön, wenn es weiterhin drin wäre. Ja, ja. Also wir sind bis jetzt da, Nele hat die Tür aufgemacht, lilaner Rauch gesehen, eine Vampirgestalt, die weggeflogen ist. Llaner Rauch, genau. Und dann ist sie in den ersten Stock sofort gerannt in die Küche zu ihrer Mutter, die gerade … Die sich ihren Kaffee gegönnt hat. Sie sich ihren Kaffee gönnt. Und dann sagt, das war nur Einbildung, äh, äh, wobei die Klingel ja kam, na ja, gut. Das war nur Einbildung, meinte ihre Mutter. Jetzt die Fortsetzung von Open AI. Nele schüttelte den Kopf und er, es wäre auch lustig, wenn sie schietelte oder so, aber er. Nele schüttelte den Kopf und erklärt aufgeregt, nein, Mama, das war keine Einbildung. Ich habe lilanen Rauch gesehen und einen Vampir in der Ferne. Die Mutter versuchte, Nele zu beruhigen, sagte jedoch, dass es vielleicht nur eine Nebelerscheinung gewesen sei. Aber das ist ja eine grosse Beruhigung. Schatz, das war nur eine Nebelerscheinung. Ach so, ja gut, na dann. Schatz, das war nur eine unheilvolle Nebelerscheinung. Trotzdem fühlte sich Nele unbehaglich. Sie packte schnell ihren Rucksack und beeilte sich, zum Pfadfinderlager zu kommen. Die Sonne begann bereits unterzugehen, als sie endlich ankam. Jetzt wurde er verschoben, wir erinnern uns.
Genau, richtig, war ein bisschen später.
Die anderen Pfadfinder hatten schon ihre Zelte aufgebaut und sassen um das Lagerfeuer.
Als die Nacht hereinbrach, erzählte Nele den anderen Kindern von ihrer merkwürdigen Begegnung.
Einige lachten, doch der Pfadfinderleiter hörte nur aufmerksam zu.
Er schlug vor. Wie sehen seine Zähne aus? Wie sehen die Zähne von dem Pfadfinderleiter hörte nur aufmerksam zu. Er schlug vor, dass sie gemeinsam nachsehen sollten, ob etwas Merkwürdiges in der Nähe war. Ah ja, sehr gut Nele, lass uns jetzt aufstehen, uns alle Tränen in unterschiedliche Richtung in den Wald gehen und einfach mal nach Nebelerscheinungen Ausschau halten. Vielleicht ist es ja nur ein Nebelerschein. Es würde mich beruhigen. Wenn wir Nebelerscheinungen fänden, dann wüsste ich, dass es alles in Ordnung ist. Gemeinsam gingen sie zu der Stelle, an der Nele den Vampir gesehen hatte. Also wieder zurück zu ihrer Wurzeln. Nach Hause. Fluchten ist räumlich enttäuscht. Vielleicht die schlimmste Pfadfinder ausflug aller Zeiten. Lass uns zu Nede nach Hause gehen, da wo wir ständig sind. Plötzlich tauchte der Lilane Rauch wieder auf. Wie, doch diesmal entpuppte sich der vermeintliche Vampir als ein freundlicher Lager-Nachbar, der mit einer Nebelmaschine spielte. Alle lachten erleichtert über das Missverständnis. Die Pfadfinder hatten eine aufregende Nacht voller Geschichten, Lieder und Abenteuer. Nele lernte, dass manchmal Dinge nicht so sind, wie sie auf den ersten Blick erscheinen. Als die Sonne wieder aufging, Third Act, Third Act, Third Act, wir haben eine gute Zeit, Happy Happy End. Nele lernte, dass manchmal Geschichten gar nicht so spannend sind, wie man denkt. Als die Sonne wieder aufging, kehrte Nele mit vielen neuen Erlebnissen nach Hause zurück, von denen wir offensichtlich nichts erfahren, aber mit vielen spannenden Sachen, was diese Nacht noch passiert ist. Oh wow, toll, Nele erzählt gar nicht von dem lila, den Rauch und der Nebelerscheinung am Ende. Rückblickend war das komplett egal, was viel krasseres noch nachts passiert, Emil ist gestorben, aber das nur am Rande. Und von diesem Tag an hatte die Nacht der Vampire eine ganz neue Bedeutung für sie und die Pfadfinder. Eine ganz besondere Bedeutung für sie. Dass nichts passiert ist und es langweilig ist. Dass es keine Nacht der Vampire war, vielleicht? Das ist die enttäuschendste Geschichte aller Zeiten. Alle lachten erleichtert über das Missverständnis. Ah, es war nur ein, wer ist das, Lagerfreund?
Lagernachbar mit einer Nebelmaschine.
Mit einer Nebelmaschine gespielt hat.
Den Liedern, den Rauch, einfach mit der Rauchmaschine.
Ja, unglaublich.
Also ich mache mir, ehrlich gesagt, noch keine allzu grossen Gedanken,
ob wir in Zukunft Kinofilme von KI sehen.
Aber das ist natürlich schon eine interessante Richtung. Ich glaube, ich bin da skeptisch. Ja, okay. Ich möchte aber jetzt auch nicht. Ich glaube wirklich, jetzt war ja die Source auch nicht so ertragreich. So, okay, du verstehe. Wenn man da jetzt einen Tarantino-Film eingespeist hätte, dann wäre das auch besser. Aber es ist natürlich der Geschichte schon treu geblieben, die natürlich Erwartungen aufbaut und dann gekonnt einfach zerstört und vernichtet und einem nicht das gibt, was man möchte. Weil man weiss ja ungefähr, wie Geschichten funktionieren, also dass irgendwas Aufregendes passiert, aber die Geschichte sagt, nee, nee, ich ziehe dir den Tempig unter den Füssen weg. Kinder, es ist so spannend, wenig an der Geschichte zu sehen, wie Kinder nicht standhalten einer Spannung, die in der Luft steht.
Es muss sofort aufgelöst werden.
Was natürlich cool ist, Kinder machen dann viele Sachen und denken anders.
Das macht natürlich Spaß.
Von daher vielen Dank für die
ans Reddit, das Podcast-Sofo
Subreddit, die immer viele tolle Ideen haben
und sie haben auch Bilder generiert mit
Bildgenerierungs-AIs
für Nele und
ist genauso, wie ich mir Nele vorgestellt habe.
Ja, doch, ist sehr schön. Ja, auch die Mutter
Aber Und sie haben auch Bilder generiert mit Bildgenerierungs-AIs für Nele. Und ist genauso, wie ich mir Nele vorgestellt habe. Ja, doch, ist sehr schön. Ja, auch die Mutter mit der Uniform. Und da war ich erstaunt, voll. Und da war ich super erstaunt, wie schnell solche Bilder generiert werden können, die ja fantastisch aussehen. Also vor allem dachte ich mir auch, vermutlich ist ja das Schwierigste an Animationsfilmen, ja erstmal die Charaktere zu bauen und so und so an sich zu rendern. Und dann der Rest ist dann so, keine Ahnung, wahrscheinlich machst du halt einen Raum und dann laufen die dann rum, weiß ich nicht, Hintergrund. Das ist halt passiert, ja. Genau, was ist halt passiert. Aber das wurde so schnell generiert, dass ich glaube, Animation ist bald einfach sehr, sehr einfach zu ersetzen. Jeder kann seine kleinen Animationsfilme machen. Ich warte immer noch darauf, dass Banksy reagiert auf diese KI-Bildergeschichte. Und ich stelle mir natürlich vor, ein in Öl gemaltes Bild, das so aussieht, als wäre es KI generiert. Mit diesen komischen Händen, mit den komischen Gesichtern, Schriften, die keinen Sinn ergeben, aber das wirklich in Öl gemalt im Louvre, sowas. Da warte ich noch auf Banksy, weil es gibt jetzt noch die Zeit, glaube ich, wir leben jetzt noch in einem Jahr vielleicht, wo diese KI-Kunst noch ein bisschen schäbig ist und danach ist er einfach perfekt. Die Schriften sind jetzt schon mit dem neuen Upgrade. Ah ja, okay, guck mal, dann ist es jetzt schon vorbei, dann ist das Banksy-Fenster schon mal zu, wo man gesagt hätte, du hast jetzt einen ganz wichtigen Punkt in der Geschichte, wo du das einmal festhalten kannst und das karikieren kannst, das Banksy-Fenster ist zu. Sorry, Banksy, die Zeit ist abgelaufen.
Sorry, Harold. TikTok, sorry. Stefan, du hast seinen Namen gesagt!
Na ja, Harold. Ach so, ach ja, ist ja geheim.
Oh fuck, können wir das rausschneiden, können wir das piepen?
Lass abbrechen, lass einfach jetzt abbrechen.
Jetzt kommen die Mäuse rein.
Die Wächter, Bänzis.
Die Ratten, ja, wenn das Podcaststudium mal so ein paar Stunden leer steht, dann kommen die Mäuse rein.
Herzlich willkommen zum Mäuse-Podcast.
Hallo, heute die fünf besten Käsesorten auf Platz fünf, Cheddar.
Cheddar mag ich ganz gerne, manchmal zu würzig, manchmal ranzig, aber du hast es zu essen, es ist ein Schmelzleckerer. Hast du von der Gertrung gehört, die wollte Cheddar essen oder nicht, ist sie gestorben? Nau, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du rand sich. Aber du hast es, es ist ein Schmähesleckerer. Hast du von der Gertrung gehört, die wollte Jelle essen oder nicht sie gestorben? Nein! Doooon! Nein! Doch, doch, doch, doch! Nein! Doch, nein! Doch, leider, ja! Nein, don't! Diese Fallen, äh, Shoutout, bitte stellt keine Mäusefallen auf! Nein, bitte nicht! Dann sterben wir! Please! Please don't! Please, please, please, please, please don't! Das war's für diese Woche, Ciao Leute, ciao im Mäuse-Podcast. Ganz kurz, aber nur kurz, ganz kurz. Ja, ganz, ganz, ganz kurz. Gott sei Dank, Gott sei Dank, ganz kurz. Gott sei Dank, man muss ja jeden Podcast hören. Es gibt ja Leute, die hören jeden Podcast an, die es gibt. Es gibt jetzt von berühmten RegisseurInnen eine Kappe, die rausgebracht wird mit Make Movies Shorter und hinten steht so, like 90 Minutes. Und ich finde es super. Ja, es ist eine gute Zeit. Das ist immer so die beste Kritik, die man mit dem Film kriegen kann. Es gibt ja so ein paar Phrasen, die man immer sagen kann, wenn man einen Film gesehen hat und wenn man den Film langweilig fand, dann sagt man, ja, entweder der Film hatte schlechtes Pacing oder der war so eine halbe Stunde zu lang. Und jetzt so, okay, halbe Stunde, war so eine halbe Stunde zu lang. Gut. Ja, kann man nicht so viel sagen, aber die Filme werden gerade wieder zu lang, das ist mir schon noch aufgefallen. Ja, die Aufmerksamkeitsspanne wird kürzer, TikTok, Instagram, Reels, Wein, Filme werden länger. Wie ordnest du das ein, warum ist das so? Naja, die Leute, die lange Filme machen, sind ja offensichtlich eine Gegenbewegung, das ist immer nur ein Scheiß, wahrscheinlich sagen die, ja, nimm mich, ich will dich, diese Nacht ist meine, ich erzähle dir jetzt vier Stundenunden nach demonstration nach demonstration sowie wenn jemand oder bewusste gegenbewegung zu schnellem tik tok wie wenn jemand ganz langsam spricht ja genau weil er sich sicher sein kann dass sie niemand unterbricht aber ich verstehe genau was verstehe genau, was du fragen willst, weil er hat die Macht und er kann es sich leisten, langsam zu sprechen, um dann auch mal, ja, ist schon klar, zu sprechen, ja, zu sprechen, ja, und ich glaube, so ist das auch mit den Filmen, die lange dauern, weil sie wissen, dass sie angesehen werden. Okay, egal. Das ist unerwartet. Egal, wie lang sie sind. Weil Iron Man 4, die Rückkehr des Lechmanns. Aber ohnehin zu, du behaltest deine Fresse. Aber ist mir mal aufgefallen, ist es, glaube ich, häufiger, wenn man nach Wörtern sucht, am Ende des Satzes. Alle meine Freunde, du eingeschlossen, sagen das Wort. Wenn Sie eher auf das Wort kommen und es sehr klar ist, was für ein Wort ich suche, würden sie dich unterbrechen und das Wort sagen. Ja, ist das denn so eine sympathische Eigenschaft? Nee, aber alle machen das, weil Leute kommen nicht mehr damit klar. Wir haben diese Zeit nicht mehr. Wir haben diese Zeit nicht mehr. Es wird das Wort gesagt. Ich war abgelenkt, ich konnte mich irgendwie nicht richtig... konzentrieren. Das würde man so nicht sagen,
konzentrieren. Es wird das Wort gesagt. Ich war abgelenkt, ich konnte mich irgendwie nicht richtig ...
Konzentrieren.
Ja.
Das würde man so nicht sagen, konzentrieren.
Also man will so, das so als nettes Hilfsangebot verklausulieren.
Was man aber meint ist, you are my time.
Genau, genau.
Ja, es ist auch meine Zeit, die wir hier verschwenden gerade.
Da ist der Zug ausgefallen und dann wurden so Busse angeboten für den Schienenersatzverkehr. Nee, Schienen, nee, wenn die Busse fahren statt des Zuges. Schienenersatzverkehr? Ist es Ersatzverkehr? Soll ich China setzen?
Ja, ich glaube schon, ja genau.
Ich weiss, was du meinst.
Also dann kamen Bus und die haben den, ja. Es ist so diese Energie von jemandem, der weg muss, aber halt einfach immer, so okay, man kann nicht gehen. Ich muss gedanklich weg von dem Ort, wo wir beide sind eigentlich.ann kann ich gehen, wann muss ich los? Das ist so, wie wenn jemand schon während des Gesprächs die Schuhe anzieht und die Jacke anzieht und dann noch so da sitzt mit dem Rucksack schon hinten drauf, so vorne gelehnt auf dem Stuhl und schon so. Ja? Okay? Ja. Nee, da war dann so vorm Bahnhof waren dann die Busse. Genau, das ist ja gerade schön. Der meinte auch noch mal, ah ja genau, jetzt passen Sie auf, heute gibt es Schienen. Ja, ja, nee, hatten wir gerade schon. Ich habe nur das Schild gesehen, es stand S-E-V. Schienenersatzverkehr, genau. Und ja, okay, jetzt bist du ja da. Schienenersatzverkehr meinst du? Ich würde nur sagen, schön, dass ihr alle zusammengekommen seid und so. Können wir jetzt auch anfangen, die Pizza zu essen, weil die wird ja auch kalt. Nicht, dass die kalt wird, ne? Paula, du hast doch auch eine lustige Story, ihr lebt in euch. Ja, ich war im Zug und dann kam dann kam der Typ und meinte so, kann ich die Fahrkarten sehen?
Und ich meinte so, ich habe das schon in der, ich habe das schon auf dem Handy gemacht mit dem App.
DB Navigator.
Ist tabu, ist auch wie tabu.
Nee, wenn der, ähm, wenn man hier, wenn man das, nee, wenn man schon sagt, wo man sitzt in der Bahn. Komfort-Tagin, Komfort-Hagin, Komfort-Hagin. Ja genau, der Komfort-Hagin. Yes, yes. So drei Leute. Thema, boop, tut, tut, tut. Ja, ja. So sind Gespräche. So sind Gespräche. Wie sind Gespräche? Gespräche sind Krieg. Gespräche sind Krieg.
Gespräche sind Krieg, seid schnell. Gespräche sind Krieg, ist es eine Abwägung zwischen Höflichkeit, Egoismus, Eigeninteresse und Sympathie. Ey Leute, wenn ihr da rausgeht, da draußen ist es wahrscheinlich im Krieg. Ja, das stimmt. Ihr müsst dann euer A-Game bringen, ihr dürft nicht langsam nach Wörtern suchen, ihr müsst euch wirklich überlegen. Aber wie ist es denn, also wenn ich jetzt mit dir rede und dann geht plötzlich dein Cringe-Helm auf, gehe ich dann weg oder warte ich dann so lange, während du, völlig desorientiert, wahrscheinlich auch mit Pfeifen in den Ohren, weil jetzt irgendwie enorme Kräfte, Gaskräfte ausgewählt wurden. Es läuft ein Song auch ganz laut. Ah ja, was ist dein Anti-Cringe-Song? Wo kommst du gut runter von Cringe? Celebrate good times, come on! Es ist Celebrate good times, oder? Celebrate good times, come on. Ach, Celebrate good times. Ich dachte, es ist Celebrate good, also wie Celebration, Celebrate good time. Celebrate? Celebrate Good time. Oder es ist Celebrate. Celebrate good times, come on! Yahoo, this is a celebration, this is a celebration. Celebration, let's all celebrate and have a good time, celebration. Are we still celebrating? Celebrate good times, come on. Did we start to celebrate already? Are we off to celebrate? Celebrate klingt nicht wie feiern, celebrate klingt wie ... Ja, es klingt wie wenn man irgendwie so sezieren, so aufschneiden. Zelebrieren. Ja, zelebrieren. Genau, es ist viel zu klassisch. Es ist viel zu technisch auch irgendwie. Zelebriere deine Zeit. Los geht es jetzt. Zelebrieren ist wirklich ein komisches Wort, feiern, deswegen hat es sich wahrscheinlich auch durchgesetzt. Das würde ich sagen, aber im Amerikanischen nicht, im Englischen nicht, da ist es noch Celebrate, to party. To party, die Feier feiern, die Party partying würde man nicht sagen. Das würde man alles nichtmals sagen ansonsten vorsätze fürs neue jahr es ist nicht unsere erste folge ich will aber das finde ich auch wichtig dass man auch im laufe des jahres noch mal so ein bisschen revue passieren lässt und guckt was man so vor sich hat dieses jahr in meinem wir hatten beim silvester feiern hat hat jemand uns so sachen auf auf den Tisch gelegt, Teller gelegt, diese Bonbons, an die man zieht und dann kommt da draus, fällt so ein Glückskekssatz, so ein Vorsatz fürs neue Jahr, etwas an das man sich halten soll. Und bei mir stand, Glück ist das einzige, was sich verdoppelt, wenn man es teilt. und das möchte ich auch mit euch teilen da draußen, denn Glück ist das einzige, was sich verdoppelt, wenn man es teilt. Dann teilt doch ein bisschen was von deinem Glück. Das ist mein Vorsatz fürs kommende Jahr und ich hoffe, wir konnten schon ein bisschen. Kannst du jetzt schon mal einen kleinen Teaser geben? Ja, ich habe gesagt, wir haben schon ein bisschen was geteilt jetzt in der letzten Stunde. Von deinem Glück war aber nicht viel dabei. Ach so, nee, ich meine so, doch, natürlich, also wir haben uns eine gute Zeit geteilt.
So, ich dachte zu, sagst irgendwas, was uns glücklich macht, oder wo du sagst, ah, da war ich glücklich in dem Moment und dann können wir das teilen.
Nein. Weil es stimmt auch nicht wirklich, wenn mir jemand erzählt, wie glücklich er ist, bin ich schlechter drauf. Das ist glaube ich nicht, was dieser Spruch meint.
Was genau meint er? Gute Zeit.
Ach so.
Gute Zeit ist was, wie verd verdoppelt wenn man es teilt oder ich bin nicht so der fan von na gut ja dann hab viel gute zeit und lasst uns auch bitte von eurer guten zeit teilhaben wenn wir es alles teilen wie so eine glücksbörse ist ein bazar jeder haut was auf den tisch genau eine kapitalistische glücksbörse wir können alle glück maximieren genau wenn wir alle richtig einfach gas geben leute wenn ihr euer glück hodelt ja dann wird es nicht mehr ihr müsst es ausgeben um zu verteilen ihr müsst raus damit okay investieren glück investieren verdoppeln investiert euch mal vor, ihr könnt euer Glück alle fünf Minuten verdoppeln.
Ihr seid die Loser, wenn ihr nicht in einem Glücks-Lamborghini rumfahren. Ja genau, wo ist euer Glücks-Lamborghini, warum habt ihr noch keinen Glücks-Lamborghini?
Wenn ich an euer Handgelenk schaue und da ist keine Glücks-Rolex, dann seid ihr verdammt nochmal Loser.
Wenn ihr zwei Monate müsst ihr verdoppeln euer Glück, dann habt ihr eine Glücks-Rolex, kein Problem.
Jetzt folgt diesem TikTok-Channel, dann könnt ihr uns helfen, euer Glück zu verdoppeln, kommt einfach rein.
Geil, man, kommt rein, macht's gut. Wir heben ab, tschüss ab, abheben, genehmigere Zeit, los geht's.
It's a Kurt Mert, Production.